now if it were up to the so-called
journalists there are not in the
mainstream media none of this would ever
get reported Biden would never be fully
vetted just like in 2008 with Barack
Obama remember this show investigated
Obama's ties to yeah unrepentant
domestic terrorist Bernardine Dohrn Bill
Ayers it was us on this show that were
digging into his deep personal
connection to Reverend Wright the Church
of Gd America and Black Liberation
Theology that so inspired him an acorn
and Olinsky in community organizing and
even the choom gang and so much more
remember throughout his presidency it
was really up to us to cover his
scandal-plagued administration because
well journalism is dead and it's been
buried quite a while unfortunately and
most of the members of the media are
nothing more than chills and an
extension of the Democratic Party they
don't care about you we the people
things have improved so much under
Donald Trump and they hate him why
wouldn't they be championing success for
the American people first interesting
question now this was perfectly
exemplified during the president's
recent trips to South Korea paid very
close attention all right president goes
to the DMZ president Trump met quickly
after he tweeted out to North Korean
dictator Kim jong-un became the first
sitting US president across the DMZ
President Trump let's see he offered no
concessions to North Korea he sanctions
are still very much in place in other
words President Trump did not try to
bribe the North Korean regime like Bill
Clinton did with your money in the
mid-90s and tell us this is a good deal
for the American people nor did
President Trump drop a hundred and fifty
billion dollars in cash you know the
currency on a tarmac to mullahs in Iran
like Biden and Obama did during their
failed Iranian nuclear deal
no this president won't try to appease
bribe dictators but he also hates
unnecessary Wars president Trump's not
an interventionist he is about America
his policy is clear America first the
American people first his foreign policy
and diplomacy surrounds economic
pressure open lines of communication we
see that with Iran Iran is desperate
because of the measures
of course the sanction the president has
put on Iran he's tapping in now to
America's vast oil and natural gas
reserves that means that straits of
hormuz are less strategically important
than ever before and by the way you want
to see the wealth of the average man and
woman in this country rise let us be not
only energy independent but let's share
our vast resources with the rest of the
world and you will see the standard of
living of every American go through the
roof
why wouldn't the news media want to tell
you that and by the way the president
views military action as a last result
the only thing he used is offered to Kim
jong-un Iran and Putin whoops drop my
pen is his time his attention he has
offered nothing more and that's not what
gets reported members of the media can't
see through their rage their psychosis
to truly understand this president
so naturally the mainstream media they
were outraged if the president cured
cancer they'd be outraged all because
the president had the audacity to simply
hold a meeting remember he got hostages
back he got remains back and he even got
the rockets from not being fired every
other day he's given nothing but time
that's it nothing else
unlike Clinton Biden and Obama take a
look at least would you it makes me want
to puke just my visceral reaction as an
American who cares about democracy and
human rights the fact that Donald Trump
is going out of his way to kiss up just
to this monster and he said something
else that I wish we wouldn't let go by
which he says it's an honor to be here
with you you know what it is not an
honor to be there with a brutal
murderous dictator the United States
president meeting with the leader of
North Korea was regarded as a plum prize
that no administration had granted the
president gave that away the United
States president visiting North Korea
was regarded as a great prize that was
given away for pretty much nothing
this was the dramatic headline the
dramatic photo the president from one
he's a great showman he pulled it off
today there's just no question about
that
it's hard to anticipate anything more
than this being a photo op that leads to
more talks that may not lead to anything
Oh might not lead to anything but maybe
it might lead to something like more
remains being sent back more hostages
free to knows where a lead that was just
one of many media meltdowns in recent
days there's nothing this president can
do that will satisfy them another
surrounded the president's brief meeting
with Vladimir Putin at the g20 summit
which I thought was hilarious press
didn't think he was strong enough on his
warning against Russian election
interference they said to him are you
going to tell him to stop meddling in
our elections here's what the president
said I think Putin for his part feels as
though that attitude a cavalier attitude
about the Russian threat to our
fundamental system gives him license to
continue to do what he's been doing and
I and and we can we can count on it
before the election in 2020 this is the
undercurrent of this entire trip meeting
with authoritarian figures basically
wink and a nod to Putin Lincoln a nod to
NBN it's also the undercurrent of his
entire presidency he likes strong men
watching it I'm appalled and did the
president just basically invite Putin to
interfere in 2020 president doesn't
realize that when he does that it sends
a terrible message to the world that the
United States is weak and that the
president is weak what did they want do
they want the president to get into a
duel with Vladimir Putin go MMA right
there in front of them did they want him
to start a public brawl at the g20 did
they honestly think the president could
say something in front of the press at a
press conference that would stop the
hostile actions of Russia well no in
reality the media just wants to blame
the president for everything
no president's been tougher in modern
day on Russia in recent years than
Donald Trump
same with Iran nobody's been tougher
with Iran and the sanctions still remain
in North Korea look at the reaction of
the president's fourth of July salute to
the America and by the way the hysteria
the phony moral outrage it was a
patriotic parade that celebrated the
military the same military that defeated
communism fascism Nazism
in Imperial Japan but they were
criticizing him even before the event
took place they knew what was going to
happen but they were wrong
watch the predictions what is the
message Donald Trump is trying to send
by rolling tanks down Constitution
Avenue who is that message to is it to
the resistance in this country
I got tanks I have this military Armada
the message is a threat but it's always
a threat when you roll you out your
military but it's to whom is the threat
and I suspect that the threat is to his
fellow Americans I'm just personally
outraged about the president hijacking
the 4th of July juxtaposition of those
images of those children in cages and
here is Donald Trump and there are these
you know flot you know things flying
overhead and the tanks is that really
the message we want to send about
America this is not what we normal think
as a democratic display of our values
but rather the values of power of might
making write of dictatorships this is
not just obnoxious tackiness this is
actually dangerous because it's
fundamentally unamerican okay the same
freedoms that are protected every day
president gave a non partisan patriotic
speech with a great history they even
made fun of that it honored our country
it highlighted the brave men and women
who served this country in uniform to
protect our liberties and freedoms but
the media painted a much more sinister
picture predictably from the 4th of July
celebration the brief meeting with Kim
jong-un the presser with Vladimir Putin
the press in this country is so corrupt
they will use any and everything to
smear this president that's who they now
are they use the same tactic with oh
just the Jeffrey Epstein case you know
the well-connected uber wealthy
financier recently indicted on sex
trafficking charges now Epstein once had
ties to many politicians and celebrities
including big ties to that guy Bill
Clinton who took very many trips on
Epstein's private plane
we called it whether they are post up
that the lalita express a Clinton denied
any wrongdoing but we covered the story
extensively well before the 2016
election rest of the media's usual
didn't ask any questions they wanted to
help Hillary at all costs and only now
the mainstream media is interested
because Epstein once had ties to
President Trump
through social events of Mara Lago now
what the media is not telling you
tonight is that Trump severed all ties
with Epstein look at the court documents
and banned him from mar-a-lago years ago
Trump was reportedly cooperative in the
2008 case against Epstein now the media
will use the sick disgusting crimes of
this guy to attack the president in
other words the guy that's really good
friends with Bill Clinton
it's beyond shameful wrong selective
moral outrage the American people know
better president's approval ratings by
the way have reached their highest point
yet and for good reason look at the
economy's booming and nobody predicted
the jobs creation in the month of June
alone 224 thousand new jobs were added
bringing the unemployment down to a
historic 3.7 percent doesn't matter what
the media says the Trump agenda is
working record low the best employment
situation since 1969 record low
unemployment for African Americans
Hispanic Americans Asian Americans women
in the workplace and youth unemployment